O ne o
[Müzik]
of
of Türkçe anlamı ne kadar sevsin
beni içeri benimsemis oldu ve
kitaplarında bahsettiği farklı ve
Aslında basit bir şekilde anlaşıldığı
üzere kaderini sevmek demek değildir 16
etmem çok daha verimli felsefe vardır
Biçer amorti tanımlarken insanı
yaşadıklarından
seçimlerinden dolayı var olanı
kabullenmesi Hatta sevmesi gerektiğini
anlatır
amorti geçmişteki hataları takılmadan
pişmanlıkları düşünmeden yaşadığınız
sevmek gerektiğidir Çünkü Geçmişte
yaşadıklarımız altında kişiliğinizin
oluşumunu bir parçasıdır bu seçimlerimiz
istediklerimiz tesadüflerle kesişmeler
bütün olarak Bizim Kaderimiz oluşturur
bu kadar inkar etmek yerine sevmemiz
gerektiğini de ponseti ben Bu felsefeyle
nasıl çalıştığımı anlatmak istiyorum
birazcık Çünkü benim için kadar
oluşturan şey seçimler ve gelişmelerdir
yaşadıklarımızı Aslında fark etmeden
veya geçici olarak seçtiklerimiz de
Kadir ise seçimlerinizle
getirdiklerinden meydana gelir sağ
olsun bakalım
İyi o zaman olduğu miniş ağladığında
etme kitapta bu fazla falan atılıyordu
kitap okuduğun dönemi Üniversitesi'nin
sonucunda seçimini yapmıştım bir katmer
kapatmıştı Bu benim için hayat
kafamda olarak çok karışıktı üstelikte
istediği bölüme girmiştik istediğim şey
yazacaktım ondan sordum fakat aynı
zamanda
istiyordum Hatta o kadar
alışmışsın ki çok çalışma hemen neden
daha çok çok sorumsuz kafamda hem de
durdu İşte bu zamanlarda ortadaki
felsefesiyle tanıştım ve farklı kitapta
okudum O an yaşadıklarımızı uçuşuyordu
ama çok sevmekle birlikte Henüz daha
farklı yapalım olmuştum O zaman de
olumsuzlukları da o kadar Kendi meşgul
ediyor bitki Aslında Yaşadığım şeyleri
satılık olmadığını davran bu
seçimleri Ben yaşadıklarımı dolarla o da
bana attı bize sonsuz takım çok
karışıktı kendime defterine veremedim
Hedef de aslına bakarsanız yoktu Tabiki
rastlantılar ve bir faktörler benim
seçmekte Ama ben de istediğim için
tamamıyla mücadele vermedi Bu sebeple de
kaderini sevmek yeri neden bu kadar
yaşıyorum birden vurdu sürekli kendine
kavga ettim kendimi üzdüm ve yaşadığım o
anların kıymetini bilmek yerine bir önce
okulu nasıl bitirebilirim sorusunu
odaklandım
ama bir şartım var senin hukuk
fakültesinde girdiğinde hem çok
uykusuzdum hem de yurtdışında eğitim
görmek üzere olduğu fotoğraf gidemediği
için hazırım sınıfında
kalmıştım hazırlık sınıfında kalmak
Aslında benim dolaylı olarak seçimde
önemli sebepten dolayı kişi gidememiştim
fakat bir çantada kalbimi yaptırmıştım
Bu sebeple de hazır kaplama.dis
sınavında kaldım O kadar önem vermedim
çalışmadım bunun sonucunda daha önce
gibi hazırlıkta kaldım bu beni daha çok
mutsuz etmekle birlikte Aslında kendime
gibi hedefledim o zaman de Dışarıdan
aldığımız bir dil sınavıyla Bu sırada
uzmanı geçebiliyorsunuz uzun sonra
çeviriyoruz yeterli Bu anamızı
yeterliydi
Bir sınıftaki herkes olun Çok zor
olacağını söyledi sağlık geçirdiğini çok
az olduğunu söyledi mi Fakat ben onları
dinlemedim ve azmedip hazırlığı ne
olursa olsun geçmeye kazandım
Ben de bu hedefi gerçekleştirmek üzere
çalıştım ve de Elif Elif onu alıp Halıcı
geçtim
daha sonra ile bir öğrenci olarak yani 2
dönemin başında pamuk ile başladım Fakat
bu da özelliklerini Bu sefer de
fakülteyi seviyordum hem de arkadaşlarım
hazırlığı geçtiği için ben ondan sonra
mezun olacaktım sonra arkadan
çalışacaktım bütün bu yaşadıklarım kadar
büyükse de alttakileri tercih de Fakat
benim uykusuzdum o zamanlar bunların
fazlalık olduğunu düşünün hayatımın en
güzel günlerinden 30 geçiyorum bu çok
önemli bir şey fark etmiyorum aslında
huzursuzlukları hep o da iyi bir hedef
görüyorsunuz ki ben mutlu olduğum
şeylere Aslında kabul ensem başarı
genellikle çektim ama kendime daha az
yıkayacaktım daha çok keyif olacaktım
kendi daha çok zor tamamlayacağım ve ben
bu şekilde bir sınıfı bitirip İstanbul'a
geldim o zaman da bir farklılığın oluştu
o çocuk senede arkadaşlarımla aynı
zamanda bitirebilecek Team Bu benim için
çok önemli bir şeydi hemen karşılığını
birlikte Bence içeriklerin temsilci işe
taşıyacaksın ve bunun benim için bir
hayal olduğunu öne aldım tekrar bu
mutluluğu ön suzun kendini bir hedef
koyma asla gene söyle vermiştim Fakat bu
da kolay bir süreç değil Ebu bitiminde
kaldığınız için çok zor olacağını
söylediler zaten hukuk fakültesi
dersleri bu çok ağırdı çok fazla Tamam
gerekiyordu benim konusunda ettikten
sonra gerektiğini söylediler bunun
sonucunda da ortalamanın düşebileceğini
söylediler
bu fotoğraf Bankası ya konuştuğum
çocukla doğru getirecektim onları
dinlemeden ve de ofisine doğru çalışmaya
başladım Normalden daha fazla ders aldım
Daha çok çalıştım Onlar daha sonra
başlamıştım Okuldan daha çok keyif
alıyordum ama üniversite hayatı aslında
o kadar da kötü değil de toplum gibi
değil de sadece ben çok kötü olacağım
Kendi inanmıştım yüzden de sürekli
mutsuzdum fakat hala Ama sen isterseniz
de anlamını kavramış
ve hala istediğini dinliyordum
A180 sonunda tahmin ellerimizin olduğu
dönemde nasıl geçeceğim kara kara
düşünürken
çok fazla ders aldım düşünürken fakülte
dekanının farklı olduğunu düşünürken
yanlış yaptığını düşünürken dört buçuk
senede bitirmeye odaklan sınıfta
kalacağını düşünürken
hayatındaki en büyük gelişme
noktalarından bir tanesi yaşadım bu
benim için hayatımda bir dönüm
noktasıydı da bir çalışma sonucunda örgü
trafik kaza geçirdim
girdim sonra
ırklarından dolayı yaptım çok hareket
yaptım yola Bir saniye geçirerek Aslında
hayatta kalmıştım kazanıp alt alta
yaptığı süre boyunca her sorguladım
arkadan Bunlar yaşıyordum bağımsızlık
mıydı neydi bu videoda kendine olan
özgüveni çok kaybettim kazanan sonra
kendimi öldürdüm etkisi bir
susun da sorguluyorum Fakat daha sonra
iyileşmeye başladı
Evet şimdi kazandı bana saf getirelim
fark etmeye başladım Öncelikle nefes
alalım ne kadar önemli olduğunu anladım
Bu Aslı üzüldüm sıkıldım her şey olursun
Çünkü Hayır sadece bir haftada yanıyordu
asla paylaşamadım ne kadar önemli
olduğunu fark ettim bu susuzluk beni ne
kadar geriye çektiğini fark ettim ve
bunun sonucunda da yaşadığım kaza bana
güç verdi
ilk öncelikle ruz olsun her şeyi
mücadele etmeyi öğren öğrenci o an ve
her daim gönüllü olanlar sayesinde benim
bana destek olan insanlar sayesinde
kendi güç buldum ve de balon insan
bitirmenin ne kadar önemli olduğunu
gösterdi
hedeflerine ulaşmak için önümdeki evlere
geçmişe odaklanmayı öğrettim ama sadece
bunda katkısı olmadı mı Evet insanlar
kesişme mide sağladı
yok artık gerçekten Elif an şeye
bilmedin kaderini sevmenin ne kadar
önemli olduğunu anlamaya başladım
kendimi Mutsuz Ev dönem gerektiğinde
yaşam sevincinin ne kadar önemli
olduğunu anladım
bu daha sonra kırma sonrasında yaşadığım
her şey bana ama lütfen fotoğrafını
derinliğin öğretti yaşadığın her
mutsuzluk çocuğu olay ehli de olumlu bir
özellik atıyordu aslında işte bu tarafta
de ben Kaderim sevmeliydim Çünkü bu
olumsuzlukların şanssızlıkları da
hayatınızda bir öğrenirse böyle bir
görevi vardı
ve O kaza yaptım fakat yılmadım
verilmesi halinde girdim yattığım yerden
hastayken çalıştığım ders Sustum adım
gösterdim ve de bu fırçaları beni bu
aldım sonucunda geçirdi Hatta
beklemediğin dediğinden daha umutlarla
gelirsin Hatta Mesela bir hocam
tekerlekli sandalye ile sınava
gittiğinde babam olduğunu sordu Ben de
olanları anlattım kaza geçirdiğimi
söyledim
Sonra Kocam bana dedi ki sana çok
istiyorsun Ben sana almayacağım dedi Ben
de çok şaşırdım
hocam dedim sınıf takdir ederseniz ben o
sıkıntı yok
İyi o zaman ben sana 90 vereceğim çünkü
bugün bu şekilde sulama gelmem benim
için yeterli dedi Biliyorum ki ben
sınavına girmeden de bunu hak etmiştim
Çünkü ne olursa olsun Mustafa girmiştim
o kadın dokusundan şey aslında şu an
beyazlık yeni trendleri farketmez
seçimlerimizle karşımıza çıkan
kelimelerdir bir hayatı olumsuz ve
şanssız olarak tabir edeceğiz kesişmeler
Aslında olumlu ve biraz şans getirecek
sonuçlar doğurabiliyor ve mesela şanssız
bir kaza sonucunda elde ettiğim şu
lafları hayatımda gördüm Bu sebeple
yaşadığımız hiçbir olarak şansızlık diye
bakmamak gerekiyor afrin'e olarak
belirtildiği şanslı görürsek ayar
Kaderimiz daha çok seviyor e geçmişe
daha kolay soruları kucaklıyoruz
En iyisi bu geçtikten sonra okulumu
bölümü sevmeye başladım Hatta ürünü
sevmek notlarım daha iyi olmasına üç
buçuk senede Şeref öğrencisi olarak
mezun olmama sebebiyet vardı hedefine
ulaşmıştır bir artı okul atıp güzel
anılar lazer arkadaşlıklar bilerek
bitirdim birinci hepsini çok büyük bir
yere
oktuay Kaderime yani seçmiş olduğum
hukuk fakültesini sevmeye başladım anda
hayatında başarı geldi aslında olacak
geldim en güzel dönemi Tadını çıkardım
birçok bilgi öğrenmeye çalıştım kendimi
geliştirmeye çalıştım
hayatımın dönüm doldurup yaşamamış olsam
artık ödevi sevecektim
O beni ayakta ne olursa olsun
başarabilecek mi görecektim herkesin
bana yapamazsın demesine karşılıyorsa
Bunların hepsi beni gelin tuz edecekti
ama ben başarmanın Tamam efendim de
bittiğinde diyordum
Ben de okuldan sonra karşında ederse
çıksın Hayat birileri pişti sürsün
sevmedim öyle hep daha çok olalım
hayattaki en büyük tutkularından bir
tanesini mesela falan attı ve hepsi
falan olmak istemiştim fakat Hukuk
Fakültesi bu hayalimi gerçekleştirdim
fakat kaza yaptım yaz iyileşince sanat
galerisinde staj yaptım hayatımı
fazlasını yapabiliriz okudum O dönemde
insanlarla görüştüğümde zaman ben
sevdiğim şey için çaba gösterecektim
Böylece hayatıma geri kutu bilmiş
olsalardı tuz gerekirdi Ömer'im olunca
da nasıl yapacağım ben sana tutumu
üzerine lisans yaptım
bu
yaşamaya başlamak kariyerini de olduğunu
anladı Belki de beni yerlerde tasarımdan
çok farklı çok çok çok yönlü bir insan
hale getirmeye başladı Bu da aslında
İnsanların onu olan barışını olmuyor da
değiştirdi
mesela yerde okumuştum
İngilizce Efendimiz yani şimdiki zaman
anlamına gelen kelime aynı zamanda Peri
anlamına da gelmektedir Yani yaşadığımız
şu an bize verilmiş bir hediyedir ve
geçmişe takılıp kalmak yerine
gelecek kaygısıyla yaşamak yerine bu anı
odaklanmalıyız ve bu hediyeyi
kaçınmalıyız O çok güzel
vefat önce hedefler hızla ya da geçmişle
Boğazı zaten ihmal edilmemelidir
çocuklarla hobilerle Birkan Dolasıyla
göre kısa bir yürüyüşle aldı
güzelleştirebilir tabi herkes böyle
şeyler söylüyorum Çok ister değişik
bunda Bunlar söyleniyor ama yaşamadan
önce anlamazdım fakat yaşadıklarının
Bunların hepsi basamak kazanmaya başladı
Ben tuttuklarını kaybettiğim zamanda bu
susuzluk ve anda kavga gücüne kaybettim
fakat tutuklularla birlikte ayaktan
keyif aldığım da başarının hayatında
planlama oldu dönüp baktığımda geçmişi
sevdiği sağlayan şeylerden birisi de ee
bunu bağlarım
bozukluklarında birlikte yaşadığı güzel
ama oldu abone
olduğunuzda sürüp ülkede izlediğin için
o yazıyı işe başlamadan önce Güney
kağıda geçmek istedim orada geçirdim
alıp boyunca Fotoğrafçılık okula gittim
uluslararası arkadaşlar edildim Çok
güzel onlar bitirdim Çok özgür listeden
Buz olmuş olduğum bütün onlar da işte
hep onların hatırlarım İşte o zaman bu
sularını da Sebep daha güzel anlar
yaşatıyor baklaları bu rakamın gördüm
çok sevdiğini yazın bir parçası Aslında
mutluluk ve aldı çok iyi anlatır yazıda
Turkey mutlu olmak için içinde
Bulunduğunuz andan daha iyi bir zaman
olduğuna karar vermek için beklemekten
vazgeçip mutluluk bir varış değil bir
yolculuktur
o çocukları çok pek çokları mutluluğu
insandan daha yüksekte haberler ağzına
da daha alçakta
Oysa Mutluluk insanın boyu hizasındadır
bu unutmayın Yarın kimseye var
edilmemiştir Yani demek istiyor ki
insanın mutluluğu ararken bulamadığı
için mutluluk Yarını beklememelidir
kaderine yaşadıklarını sebep mutluluğu
anla yaşamak gerekir bize son sınıftaki
Ben de işlemini bilmiyordu ön
yargılarıyla kendini mutsuz ediyordu
Fakat daha sonra yaşadıklarını kabul
edip sevmeye başladığımda ne istediğini
anlamaya başladım Her zaman
beklediğimizi karşıda çıkarmıyorum ben
şunu anladım ki bazen Beklenmeyen
kesişmeler yani kadar bizim için olumlu
sonuçlar doğuruyor
yok abla Pazartesi hala anlamaya
uygulamaya çalışıyorum maalesef her
zaman toz pembe değil istediğiniz gibi
gitmiyor Bütün bunların burada yaşamış
olmam anlatıyor olan benim Bunu anladım
anlamına da gelmiyor Hala kafa
karışıklıkları yaşıyorum bazen bunun
sorgulamaktan mutsuz olduğum onları
Tabii ki oluyor ama kendi hedeflerine ve
hedeflerinin ölme koyduğu fırsatlara
kesiştiği insanlara ve olaylara
bırakarak Aslında sevgili yolu takip
etmeye çalışıyoruz bunu yaparken de
geçmişini yaralarımı mutsuzluklarını
sebep Aslında hepsini beni seçim
olduğunu anlayıp yola devam etmeye
gayret gösteriyorum biliyorum yaşadığın
her şey Kaderime yetiştikleri benim
geçişli Parçası benim sağ Kaderim
oluşturan seçimlerle kesişmeler ve kavga
etmeyi bırakıp anda yaşadığı mutluluğu
hissederse ama sakın fark edersin
hayatına uygulamaya başlıyor
bu yani çok farklı insanların yüceliği
kadar serisinden geliyor kaderin senin
ellerinde sahip olmak geçmişe takılmayın
altı güzelliklerini yaşamak bana başarı
kariyer Aşk Aynı hayat dahil Hayatın her
alanında zorluklarla mücadele edip
Futbol benim için bu önemli belki sizler
için Hakkı iz bırakacak hikaye
dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ederim